[Musique]
c'est une carrière difficile au Nigeria
à travers mon école primaire personne
personne ne nous a parlé de
la possibilité d'être artiste donc je n'ai
jamais suivi cette voie
donc à l'origine j'ai commencé par vouloir
devenir ingénieur en informatique
et en cours de route j'ai découvert  passion
pour l'art
[Musique]
donc
nos dirigeants jouent avec nous
et ils ne nous prennent pas au sérieux ils
font les choses les plus drôles et à la
fin on se demande
quelle aurait pu être la logique
derrière cette action
[Musique]
euh  le prêtre arc-en-ciel est fondamentalement
quelque chose qui parle de
la discrimination contre les personnes lgbtq
du point de vue religieux, donc
peu importe ce à quoi les
gens font face, nous
devrions toujours respecter
la valeur des vies humaines
[Musique]
la plupart des apprenants ici quand  on leur
demande de s'exprimer,
ils font toujours le lien avec des problèmes
que
vous connaissez tous deux autour de la justice sociale, je
pense que c'est juste à cause de cette
déclaration
[Musique]
vous